Go enjoy your PTSD app,
this guy is directly cattle.
>> 15 years out from Iraq, eat my balls. Does he want to
get banned? Like I I don't understand. Why would you do this?
Do you even have your balls remaining or did a IED explode them
for you, dumbass? Shut the up. Bro, like one of my best friends
died from a I like
>> Sorry, that's not strictly
Sorry, that's not I I have to control myself.
So, without further ado, let's get into this Hasan stuff, okay?
We have We've got to watch it, okay? I've been told that this
is where it starts. For years and years, all of these institutions
have taught Americans that actually do have dual loyalty to the
state of Israel. Ironically enough, anytime they talk about Israel,
this is the thing that care about.
For years and years, all of these institutions have taught Americans
that actually do have dual loyalty to the state of Israel. Ironically
enough, anytime they talk about Israel like this, they don't
realize
that they're telling random Americans who haven't been indoctrinated
since
to to learn about the necessity of of the Israeli state
that haven't been indoctrinated with Zionism, that this is the
this is the thing that you care about first and foremost and
only the only thing that you care about in America.
They do worship law.
Islam always. Allah does the
Oh, you know, just like Islam. I'm a American, go [__]
yourself. Islam always. Allah does the non-believers.
Dude, the American military, people talk about how the American
military gets rid of their like physical fitness requirements.
They allow like fat Americans in and that's like how how that's
similar to the what do you call it? Like the reduced requirements
for women. But nobody talks about how they have to be. They just
have to be lowering the IQ requirements,
How else do you explain this guy being a veteran, okay? believers.
Oh, you know, just like Islam. They do worship law, Islam. This
guy is such a This guy is directly cattle, okay?
>> Dude, I I'll be honest, man. I'm just happy that Hasan's
on the same page cuz I I feel this now every single time.
I get Yeah, I get how people
hated Islam after 9/11, okay? If you're sitting here doing the
the 9/11 like, "Oh, [__] these in 2026,
you are actually cattle. You are total
You
are basically like this should be
evidence that could be submitted to get your to get you disenfranchised.
Like you literally don't get to vote anymore. You don't have
like a an internal monologue, you don't have a thought process,
you have nothing. You don't get to vote anymore. You've shown
yourself to be literal cattle. You you don't get to vote, you
don't have You are just somebody who could be manipulated by
others. That's the only purpose for your
This is also the double standard, okay? I can spend a good deal
of time talking about anti-Semitism in this chat, okay? But let's
be real, this is the also this is the reason why I say that as
far as systemic discrimination goes,
there's no comparison.
Islamophobia is totally normalized, okay? It's totally normalized.
Now, anti- I too Semitism is getting there, but it's nowhere
near the same, right?
The greatest example of this is you can have a congressperson
like Andy Ogles or Randy Fine come out and be like, "Every Muslim
in this country, they all have to be killed or whatever." And
no one would bat an eye. There would be no censures. But if someone
were to say They really do be like that, right? We have to get
rid of these savages. And then they're like, "Wait, what do you
mean these savages?" Well, people who like believe in Sharia
law. It's like a it's a whole world of ideas. Dude, I'm like
so far off of I used to be one of the people who's like, "No,
I think you can Like it is about culture and and culture's like
important in all this and you know, I do think Islam is broadly
not compatible with like Western values, you know? All of this
[__] And it's like that could be true,
but it's almost something that I oppose categorically now because
I just see it being used to manipulate people only. Like I don't
even care about the actual fact of the matter anymore. It's just
being used to manipulate people. Like they don't Nobody who says
that in 2026 actually cares about Western values at all. They
don't give a [__] It's all of the people who are
just like, "No, no, no, let us bomb [__] No, they're
they're [__] Muslims. You don't you understand? They're
Muslims, they're bad. They're Muslims, they're
Like, "Okay." Think that about Of course, their career would
be over.
Both of these Both of these statements are completely unacceptable.
Except one is accepted by institutions.
15 years out from Iraq, eat my balls.
Do you even have your balls remaining or did a IED explode them
for you, dumbass? Shut the [__] up. >> Oh,
that's really insensitive, Hasan. Won't you think about all of
the people who had friends and family killed by IEDs right now?
Hasan! Talking about
You are an infinitely bigger terrorist than any random Muslim
ever could be,
Shut your [__] ass up. Go enjoy your PTSD app,
No!
Imagine Bro, Frogan moment. Uh-oh.
Frogan moment right there. Uh-oh.
This is going to be funny for Twitch. What is Twitch going to
do now? Cuz I'm pretty sure that's the precise like Frogan phraseology
right there that got her banned.
we're not to it yet, but watch how Hasan follows this up. It's
very funny because
Like does it matter? I I guess Frogan was going in on people
who had nothing to do with it, right? And but right there, Hasan
does say the PTSD comment.
Uh, I don't know. I'm trying to think cuz the way you're supposed
to look at it, technically the way you're supposed to look at
it, okay? Is with with that comment, think about it if you said
that to black people some black stereotype or something, right?
I think so. Is the Frogan comment? Oh, hold on. How close is
it? We'll see how different this is. Give me a second. >> pity
at all for any soldiers. This dress, thank you so much. I will
never have any pity for any
So, this is like not somebody confronting her, a little different,
>> Veteran is a race. Veteran is a protected class like
race is in the same way, yes. So, you're not allowed to discriminate
against race like under the law. Sorry, against um veteran status
under the law. I hope you get PTSD.
Thank you so much. I will never have any pity for any
>> Is US military? I hope you get PTSD.
I mean, categorically a little bit different, right? Um it's
a legal thing in terms of hiring. It's an equal protections thing.
They're they're like a group under the equal protections clause,
I think. So, under in hiring and like a couple other categories,
you cannot discriminate against somebody based on veteran status
at all. You know? Okay, well. I I do The ones I do I The ones
I'm like whatever about, the US soldiers, are the ones that like
acknowledge that like what they did was wrong. They didn't know
well back They didn't know back then.
Whatever. You're You're a good person in my book. I'm like a
Tom, thank you so much for the 10 gifted. I hope you get PTSD.
Gifted, gifted, gifted, gifted. Jesus Christ, people hate the
US Army in that
That's wild. >> Imagine having the audacity to be like,
"Yeah, I went to Iraq. I went to Iraq." And it's actually Islam
that's the biggest danger. You're the danger,
You're a danger to your family and a danger to yourself. This
is This is one of those things where it is like people love using
stereotypes to attack other people. It's just like we've sort
of ruled some things out culturally, but realistically at their
at their base, their base instinct for everybody, okay? Is to
just use like some
some characteristic of your identity to attack you. It's just
the thing that feels best when you really hate someone, unfortunately,
okay?
Unfortunately. You're a danger to your
Statistically, you're likely to kill your family. Did you know
that? >> Actually Islam that's the biggest danger. You're
the danger, idiot.
You're a danger to your family
and a danger to yourself. Oh boy.
Somebody in chat just put hello YouTube like stare. Dude, it's
so obvious he's going to get clapped for this. I'm I'm positive
he gets clapped for this one.
Lol, that's getting clipped, Lamah. I don't give a [__]
Dude, shut the [__] up. If you go to Iraq and you
learn that lesson, you realize that that was wrong, you're welcome
here. You come back from Iraq and you talk about how this was
actually awesome and I [__] hate Islam,
then [__] you. You didn't learn anything. You're
goddamn Jeez, it really maps onto that Frogan thing though. It's
not quite the same, but it gets real close, doesn't it? >> cattle.
You're sending other people like you to be in a similar predicament
to yourself. Whatever, [__] I'll start live streaming
on YouTube tomorrow. Suck my dick. Now, you're getting clipped.
By who? The people that have been literally begging for American
sons and daughters to go and die in Iran for the He does Wait,
he might actually want the ban though. He can't really make money
on Twitch in like the same way. Like it's only from his audience
he makes money on Twitch. And he probably makes more streaming
on YouTube just from ads than he makes from his audience in like
any given day. So, like realistically,
uh dude,
does he just does he just want to get clapped? He wants to move
over, but he doesn't want to He wants to be forced to move over,
right? Obviously. the last 2 weeks by people who keep going,
"Yeah, based. No, we got to give more money to
Those people
those people who are going to turn around and then now act as
though they give a [__]
about veterans?
The same people like Asmongold who celebrated when that Navy
SEAL
uh with his with his uniform had his arm
Really? [laughter] That's what we're doing? And Twitch Actually,
it's only wrong to make fun of veterans. It's only wrong to mock
veterans to say they deserve pain when they're protesting Israel,
okay? That's Sorry. Sorry, it's only correct to do so. It's wrong
in every other case. It's only correct to do so if opposing Israel.
Then it's Then they deserve whatever happens to them, okay? >> can apply
this double standard when one veteran is getting their arm uh
broken by an American congressperson for opposing America waging
Israel's wars. When Twitch doesn't ban Asmongold for laughing
at that and saying, "Yeah, based." and that he deserved it. When
Twitch literally doesn't say a single damn thing about that,
but then turns around and tries to ban me for this This platform,
I will never come back
Hasan Hasan going to YouTube if they ban him? Dude, that's crazy.
Throws down the ultimatum on Twitch. Uh guys, if you you ban
me for that after not banning
You know what Twitch has to do, right? Ban them both. Ban them
both. Get them both out. That would piss so many That would piss
literally everybody off. It would be so funny. They won't do
it cuz it would [__] them over. But that would be
so funny. Could you imagine? Bro, that's That's crazy to to pull
your dick out and put it on the table and say, "Ban me. See what
happens. Ban me. See what happens." Mr. Saltman, one more mission.
No, Dan can't comment on this. I actually need to add Dan in
my Discord right now.
Dan, how upset are you that you swore off of all
Hasan content and today he said he hopes a vet enjoys their PTSD
and that they're probably going to their
or themselves.
>> Good times. Good times. Good times.
Oh, this Yeah, sure this was yesterday. Sure sure sure. Y'all
are a bunch of dumb
too for being like, "Oh, you're going to get clipped." dumb
doesn't even realize his own lived experiences should have taught
him a very valuable lesson. Wow. I man The funny thing is is
I do think I don't think you could actually soy about this. I
don't think anybody could Who could soy about this? Maybe Hutch.
I think Hutch does soy about it. But I don't think Asmongold's
got no room to soy on this at all. Right? Absolutely no room
to soy on it whatsoever. And every single person who does get
mad about this, all they'll do is they'll go, "Well, I don't
I don't agree with that. I don't know if you should be banned,
but like it's Twitch TOS that you can't do that." It's I Listen,
I wouldn't want you banned for it, but like it's Twitch As they
submit like 85 reports, as they post the clip constantly. I I
don't want you banned, but like it's Twitch TOS. They should
They should follow their TOS. What was that? We love you, Hasan.
Hasan is losing it.
Insta ban. Get him out. Get him out.
Get him out of here. Oh, was it like the actual disingenuous
Uh I don't really care, but like you should you should get banned.
Disgusting. Okay. I think that That's got to be it, right?
That's got to be it. He's just going to start banning people,
anybody who's who's posting about it. That's pretty funny. Okay,
hold on. Uh let's see. I've got I've got a lot more here. Sorry,
I'm uh getting my bearings real quick. Okay, we got that. And
so this was yesterday, all right? This was yesterday. We get
the Ok post this morning. Ok will never miss a chance to get
the Hasan clips out. Although, I actually shouldn't do the Ok
post. I should actually go over to Best
Ok just Anytime Best Friend posts something cool Ok doesn't even
like at him directly in the tweet. He doesn't do any He just
is like, "Oh, [__] it. Uh like I'm just going to
take this." And he's like, "Best friend Source Best Friend."
Kind of gay, in my opinion, okay?
Yeah, kind of gay, in my opinion.
I I don't necessarily like that Best Friend does anti-Hasan content
all the time, but Best Friend is like not a [__]
loser, okay? At least he posts his own [__] So, Hasan
[__] crashes out on veteran and threatens to leave
Twitch forever over Asmongold double standard if
Let's see. What do we got for replies? Here's the logs of the
person Hasan was responding to. Interesting you cut that
Oh, let's see. I am higher I I I high IQ. Islam rule all. Down
with Israel.
Islam good. Islam take over all. Iran big. Islam good. Win all
very much. Dude, what was the community note? I think it's just
about the policy, right? Hasan violated Twitch's hate conduct
and harassment policy. Veteran status is explicitly considered
a protected characteristic. Content or behavior that attacks,
harasses, or promotes hatred based on someone's veteran status
is hateful conduct.
Damn. What happened to [__] around and find out,
by the way? Like I think Asmongold goes off on this. What happened
to [__] around and find out? What happened to that?
Can anybody explain that to me? This guy goes to the chat. He's
like talking [__] He wants to get hit. Right? That's
what this guy How is this guy not a thousand times worse than
Renee Good? Come on, man.
This guy's asking for it. He's demanding Hasan put hands on him,
okay? It's [__] up. Watch xQc will not understand
and hop on the Hasan hate train and take the wrong positions.
At xQc is about to have the pro-war-on-terror
that it brought peace and security to the region. But nice work
supporting American Dude, this guy is just
>> 46 comments, four likes on the tweet. Sorry, that's
very funny to me.
>> I've seen this guy reply to some of my posts before.
That's just very funny. 46 replies, four likes.
Dude, that's nuts. That's an insane ratio on the tweet, okay?
Hutch came out. Hutch had a comment. Let's see Hutch's comment.
Chatter Wild wild. Chatter was definitely well out of pocket
with the rhetoric, but Hasan's reaction here is fully psychotic
and out of bounds. I
Dude, it's Okay.
All right.
I just He says this in a way that this would never affect him
collaborating with a person at all, right? Like Like this doesn't
actually bother Hutch at all in any real way.
And not
It just doesn't. It obviously doesn't. We got a Tectone tweet.
Tectone getting in on it. Let's check Let's check it out. Tectone,
guy who like hates Twitch. Okay. Hasan [__] berates
a PTSD veteran live on stream. Well, he doesn't actually Wait.
Unless did the log say that he has PTSD or does is Tectone just
doing the same thing? Perpetuating harmful stereotypes
on
I don't think this guy said he had PTSD. I think Hasan said,
"Enjoy your PTSD."
assuming he did. After hallucinating and blaming Asmongold for
all of his own Hasan's wrongdoings.
Says if this gets clipped and he gets banned, he will never stream
on Twitch again. Twitch, you right now have the opportunity to
do the funniest, most based [__] right now.
Bro, is this Is everybody's IQ just draining away like the way
they write tweets?
Twitch, you right now have the opportunity to do the funniest,
most based [__] right now.
The Asmongold vod. The Asmongoldy vod. We're here. 503. But who
cares? I don't have any ill will towards AngryJoe. Honestly,
I really could care less. So, uh let's move on. Uh anyway, so
this is a new one, right? Hasan says, "Enjoy
Just consider hateful conduct on Twitch, which generally nets
you a 30-day permanent or permanent ban, by the way. Uh anyway,
so this is a new one, right?
Can I Can I share a Discord message? >> says, "Enjoy PTSD."
Why would you do this?
Does he just Does he want to get banned?
Does he want to get banned? Like I I I don't understand. Why
would you do this? Like it's just it it's You don't for people
that die and complain about PTSD. Well, when do I hope for somebody
to
No no no, real quick. Real quick.
Let me He does revel in people dying quite often. So, you could
say like I generally hope for things that make me laugh. And
like as happy as Asmongold looks when Renee Good gets hit by
that car, okay? Like when he goes on stream and he goes, "Rip
Bozo." I just wish
That's like the kind of thing I think about hoping for or or
wanting to have happen, right? Anything that makes me about as
happy as Asmongold is when he watches like illegal immigrants
getting like thrown to the ground, assaulted by ICE officers,
and taken deported, taken pulled away from their families. Anything
that makes him Sorry, would make me as happy as he looks in those
moments, all right?
Those are things I hope >> no no no no no no no no. When
do When do I hope for do I hope for anybody to die?
When do I Who Who did I hope that was going to die?
What is it? Is it a Is it a
Guilty as charged.
Is it a Rip Bozo? What is it exactly?
Like he can't even hide the fact that he says Rip Bozo, that
he's that that means he's psyched that somebody died. What did
you say when Renee Good died? Rip Bozo. I'm curious. And yeah,
that's it. I sure I don't think it's Okay, hold on hold on hold
on hold on. Yes, we need that to be tweeted out, okay?
So, I've Guys, we've heard Asmongold apparently just basically
says on stream here that he's hoping for Tectone's
No no no, real quick. Real quick.
No no no no no no no no no. When do When do I hope for anybody
to die?
When do I Who Who did I I that was going to die?
What is it? Is it a Is it a
Guilty as charged. Yeah. Damn. Is it a
Tectone? Rip Bozo.
What is it exactly? I thought these were his friends. I thought
these were his
What the [__] Total Asmongold calls for total Nux
Taku, Tectone,
and Lacari on his stream live. That's so [__] up.
Why would he do
Why would Asmongold Why? And yeah, that's it. Dude, do be honest
for once. No, the reason why I hope people die all the time.
I do. But the difference is that the people that I hope die are
like Like that So So that's the difference, right? So do you
understand that like Okay, when I ever I hope somebody has something
bad happen to them, it's like a
versus like whatever somebody else does something bad happen
to them, it's like an American
to be fair, in Asmongold's in Asmongold's defense, when you ask
him about Vietnam veterans, he just says flip a coin, okay? Cuz
he knows Hey, they're both It's both things, okay? It's both
things at the same time. Okay, you see the difference there?
They like went out there to fight for their country.
Like I don't want to have those guys
I don't want them to die. I don't want them to have PTSD either.
You understand that? Gazans, school kids, medics. Okay, all right.
Let me Let me just line it up for you, okay? I don't want the
Gazans to die. I don't want kids in a school to die. I don't
want medics to die. I don't.
I'm woke.
I'm so woke. I don't want I don't even want kids in a school
to die.
I wonder if he'll engage with like the fact that this guy's saying
this because you've basically run tacit defense for those people
dying. Like I wonder if he can understand why somebody would
say this, right? Like I'll say okay, maybe you didn't say you're
psyched that those people died, right? But you did say oh well,
you should go and kill medics. As in like that's something that's
a tactic we should do. I mean, I think that's getting pretty
close to saying you want them to die. But it's like saying well,
you live in Iran, but you don't have to fight in the war. Listen,
you're a medic? Why would you
Why would you have to fight? That's how woke I am now.
You're getting banned. You're getting banned. You're
You know you're And I don't want to hear anything else you have
to say, okay? So except combat medics, well I don't want anybody
to get killed. I don't think that's No, of course not. It's crazy.
Worst mistake you ever had trying to get a leftist chatter to
understand the difference between a and a veteran.
Dude, I don't want to do it cuz I'm technically on Twitch right
now, okay?
But let's just let's let's not pretend that there is a stark
harsh line there, okay? We're just going to kill That's a hard
one. Way to start a stream. I know that, man. And when you say
Like what I feel like they're baiting me. They He's baiting me
right now, okay? Yeah. Hold on. Tectone's dad, Asmongold, Tectone's
dad. Where do we go in that? Is that a coin flip, too? Tectone's
father?
Technically Let me Let me just be clear. He didn't for Rockies.
I know you want to let him go cuz he did he You thought he the
Rockies. No, it was actually like American women. So I hope that
That should change your Your America first, right? certain things.
Yeah, you do You don't do yourself favors sometimes cuz you say
something that sounds extreme when you don't think about it,
but reasonable when you do. I really I really do I I I really
don't do myself a lot of favors with that, do I? I think you're
totally right, actually. I am such a jackass. I'm fully aware
of that. Everybody knows this. I mean, I'm not Listen, I I'm
not going to I will take that criticism because you're right,
and you know you're right.
Anyway, let me watch this. I I don't know what's going on here.
Is it some kind of like usual crash out or
Is this like a special one? Let's take a look at it. 15 years
out from Iraq, eat my balls. Eat my Do you even have your balls
So So what is this here?
remaining or did a IED explode them for you, dumbass? Shut the
[__] talking about Islam.
You are an infinitely bigger terrorist than any random Muslim
ever could be. Do we want to look at the the the terrorist attacks
that have happened in Europe and America?
Like I Okay, I don't know how to put it
It's just never He's never going to engage, right? It's It sucks
to watch this cuz sometimes I want to be serious and like engage
and and talk about the topics. But it's like okay.
Do you think like the random like a random Iraqi civilian saw
the US as a terrorist organization or a military engaged in like
a lawful in lawful conduct, right?
How many You want to talk about civilian casualties in the past
30 years between the Middle East and the United States? Do we
want to compare those numbers? Do you want to run that Do you
want to run those numbers, Asmongold? Cuz I I have a feeling
America's not going to come out looking good if we run those
numbers.
Now I know people are like well, actually it's legal for America
to do that though. It's like a It's like a military op It's like
the military. It's like okay, but if you're one of those civilians,
if you have empathy for those
Those civilians didn't control Saddam's actions. Those civilians
didn't control the Ayatollah's actions, right?
Come on, man. Do we want to We don't We don't want to take that
to the bank, do we? We don't want to look that We don't want
to look this up. We'll just take his word for it. Take his word
for it. If that's so true, so true, you're right.
Okay. Dumbass.
Shut your ass up. Go enjoy your PTSD
Why would you say this?
You knew Frogan got in trouble for that. Why would you say this?
I feel like he said specifically because Frogan got in trouble
for it and he
I I feel like he said it intentionally. He knew the thing that
he's not supposed to say and he felt compelled to say it directly.
Who's to say he had PTSD either? Like he never even said he had
PTSD.
So So you're saying that you want to Now this is another You
know what I'm starting to see? I'm starting to see a pattern.
This is weird. It really is. And yeah, how much you want to bet
he's going to be banned on Sunday again? I don't know, man. I
don't. And what What a weird thing to say, man.
Muslim ever could be.
Did Asmongold respond to the Emiru thing? I guess he can't, Kenny.
Shut your ass It's obvious that Islam has a problem with terrorism.
It's obvious. That Now it Who am I Who am I getting this information
from?
Yeah, but Vurin, I think you could understand how if you said
this about a trans person specifically, like a specific trans
person, if you were to cite statistics at a specific trans
you're you're a bigger danger to yourself than anybody else.
I don't think that goes very well on Twitch, hypothetically,
right?
You know what I'm saying?
I still think it's probably a thing you can't technically do.
Will he get banned? I don't think so. I think the comment about
how he'll just leave increases the chance he gets banned
right? Cuz Cuz then you're you're basically laying down a threat
for the platform and platforms broadly shouldn't just let those
kind of threats like You don't want to give the optical You don't
want to give the the optics off as the platform that that threat
killed you from taking action, right? The threat is actually
worse for him. Muslims.
They're the ones that say it. They're the ones that are worried
about this in their own countries. This isn't like some kind
of crazy like oh my god, where is this opinion coming from? They
think
Oh god. Go enjoy your PTSD ass, you. Imagine having the audacity
to be like yeah, I went to Iraq. I went to Iraq. And it's actually
Islam that's the biggest danger. You're the Well yeah, obviously
it's the biggest danger. Like guess what Saddam Hussein was.
Like Oh, I didn't realize it was going to be this
Oh no.
Now, correct me if I'm wrong, weren't the Ba'athists explicitly
like secular, like they're not religious? That was the whole
point was it was like all Arabian like Arab nationalism.
I don't even know if it was Arab nationalism. But I thought it
was explicitly like that they were not religious. They were not
running like
In fact, this
Yeah, okay.
I That's like the dumbest thing he could have said. He just said
the dumbest thing possible. And that By the way, I'll make it
clear. If he hadn't done something before, well right there,
did he just assume somebody's religion based on their ethnicity
and based on their their location in the world? Sure seems like
ethnicity would be a protected class. Are you using a stereotype
against somebody of a certain ethnic group? Is that what you're
doing,
Wow. Like I mean, that guy was pretty crazy, wasn't he? That
guy was a nutball.
And yeah, absolutely it was. I mean, objectively, right? I'm
not crazy here. It's just objectively what he did. He just objectively
took this guy's ethnicity,
through like basically tried to suggest he's like a radical Islamic
terrorist
when that's not at all his ideology. It's not even a little bit
dangerous.
You're a danger to your family.
He's a danger to his family? Wow, okay. I didn't know this. This
is new.
And a danger to yourself, douchebag. I didn't know this either.
Wow, he's learning Okay. Wow, he's getting really personal about
this. He's getting really personal. Wow, how Why Why is this
so personal? Like No, that's getting clipped. Lemao, I don't
give a [__] dude. And you see how Like And this is
what I've said before about like the whole mean girl the mean
girl aesthetic that Hasan has. Hasan is incapable of having a
conversation with somebody that he disagrees with without insulting
their appearance. And I know this isn't actually true. I know
he's been able to do it before, but I think that overwhelmingly
that's not the case. Like it's like he has to go for some sort
of like middle school level insult on them, whether he's talking
about me, some random chatter, or some, you know, politician
that he disagrees with. I think it's very common. Shut the [__]
up. If you go to Iraq and you learn that lesson, you realize
that that was wrong, you're welcome here.
Was it just that appearance is personal, I guess?
I'm trying to think like he's not Is Asmongold just like seething
about the fact that Hasan calls him ugly? Is that all that's
happening right now? Is that literally the only thing taking
You come back from Iraq, talk about how this was actually awesome,
and I hate Islam, then [__] you. You didn't learn
anything. You're goddamn cattle. >> Well, wait a minute.
Wait, wait. You didn't learn anything. What What Wait a second.
So, he was supposed to go to Iraq to learn about Islam? I thought
he was supposed to go to Iraq to try to, you know, like do whatever
the military's mission was there. Like, I'm pretty sure Iraq
isn't like a high school, right? I mean, I I I I don't think
so. I hope not. I hope hope not. I mean, if again, if Asmongold
had read stuff about this, he'd know that Iraq was like a massive
failure early on, at least in terms of the nation-building stuff,
until they started trying to win hearts and minds. And so, probably
the lesson a soldier should take away from Iraq is that if you
constantly treat somebody as the enemy, as something something
to be destroyed, you will never gain their support, you will
never have any success against them. They will constantly fight
you at every turn, and you will lose significantly more of your
friends, yourself, than you ever plan to, okay?
But by treating them like human beings, by by humanizing yourself
to them, humanizing them in turn, you actually can accomplish
something. Although they didn't do it early enough or well enough,
and obviously that whole project fell apart, but hey. >> Like,
I I I What are we doing here? You're sending other people like
you Like, basically in Iraq, they were dealing with IEDs all
of the time, when they were just bombing the [__]
out of everything and trying to roll through the country. Once
they started like talking to people, trying to build connections
with people, right? Then people be like, "Hey, don't go over
there. There's like that that doll over there that's actually
is going to blow you up. Don't do it, right?" As soon as you
make the other people think of you as people, this you should
learn that it not everybody over there is a crazy Islamic terrorist.
Most people are just humans. You make any kind of connection,
they're fine with you. >> Yeah. To be in a similar predicament
to yourself. Whatever, [__] I'll start live streaming
on YouTube tomorrow. Suck my dick. Now, you're getting clipped.
Uh-huh. I mean, it's to be fair, this is a pretty bad It's a
bad clip. It is. Like, I think everybody can acknowledge like
I mean, he even he knows. Like, he knows it's a bad clip. Everybody
knows this is a bad clip. Another clip of Hasan of of
I don't even This one seems less bad to me. Like, he's not speaking
in generalities, right? To me, it's always like you say a lot
about yourself when you're speaking generalities, and you're
going to use some sort of like um like identity-based insult.
Which I do all the time, by the way, so I can't even throw the
first stone on this. Which like Asmongold does. He just did it
with Saddam Hussein. Which everybody who's complaining about
this does and thinks is based. Techtone absolutely thinks it's
based, right? He loves to talk [__] about people.
He loves to be like racist, homophobic, all of this stuff. And
then it's like, uh [__] veterans, and he starts like
crying and [__] himself. Crying, [__]
everywhere, right?
It's just dude, if you want to If you want to play that game,
if you want to be that guy who's like super based, and you have
all these all these opinions, you say crazy [__]
do not be a [__] when it comes to you,
That's the only That's the only rule of being racist. You can
be racist. Just let other people be racist to you. Let other
people be prejudicial about groups you care about, right? If
you're going to constantly If you're going to piss and [__]
yourself over somebody doing that, then just get in line with
the rest of the wokes, okay? Just Just get back on your woke
side. Another streamer on Twitch wishing PTSD
on another American veteran. It looks bad. It does. It looks
really bad. I don't know what else to
Someone did jihad on a Michigan
Suspect dead after ramming vehicle into Michigan synagogue, officials
say. I mean, what part makes you think
that this was like an Arab person? Even less. Why would you say
jihad?
See what you're doing? See See what you just did there?
Did you just assume that this was an Arab person who hit the
synagogue?
Did you just make that assumption?
Oh my god. >> The people that have been literally begging
It was, though? Yeah, I I'm just racist. I would have bet that
it was, okay? Michigan?
Michigan? Yeah, that's definitely an Arab terrorist. >> for
American sons and daughters that go and die in Iran for the last
2 weeks. But people who keep going, "Yeah, based." It's always
You see, when people make fun of whites, I just I let that roll
off my back,
Cuz I'm not going to get all ass mad about it. It's about me.
It is. It's all Even when it's a group By the way, it could be
a group I care about. And I I'll say I'm not going to make fun
of that, but I'm also not going to soy about it, right? That's
what you could do. You could say, "Listen, I disagree with that.
I care about that group, but I know that's hypocritical on my
part. So, while I'm not going to participate, I'm just going
to I'm not going to act like that person should be canceled."
Always, I'm the most important character. Everything is always
about me. See, when Hasan gets in argument with a chatter, and
then he gets mad at the chatter, you might not believe it, but
it's actually my fault. No, we got to give more money to Israel.
Who's saying this? Those people
What What does this have to do with Israel? Again, why is this
It's about Israel again. Oh my god. It's always about Israel.
Holy [__]
Those people who are going to turn around Yeah. >> and then
now act as though they give a
about veterans. >> Uh-huh. The same
They They love to call this out that oh, Hasan makes it about
Israel. It is about Like, that The thing he's pointing out about
you, that was about
You literally cheered for that guy getting hurt. People like
Asmongold who So, it is me. It's It is all about me, as usual.
Okay, so yeah, I care about veterans. Of course, I care about
veterans. That's why I don't want to have our money go to Somalians,
so it can go to veterans.
Yeah, exactly.
That's the whole point. Yeah, I'm glad we're putting these things
together. >> Uh with his with his uniform head >> Well,
I I think now we're I thought he he wasn't a Navy SEAL, number
one. He was a Marine, I'm pretty sure. And so, like but you see
like Navy SEAL is like I I think this is like an elite unit of
like uh you know, of like the Navy. So, he's like trying to dial
it up, right? And so, it's like, "Okay, now we're trying to get
like the maximum amount of of like moral high ground here, right?"
I mean, that's very clearly what we're trying to do. It's so
obvious. Arm broken? He got his arm broken. Yeah, he did. Rip
Bozo. Shouldn't have done it. Really? That's what we're doing?
Twitch can apply this double standard when one veteran is getting
their
broken
by an American congressperson for opposing America waging Israel's
wars. When Twitch doesn't ban Asmongold for laughing at that
and saying >> Why would they ban me for that? I mean, I
wasn't wanting his arm to get broken because he's a veteran.
I wanted his arm to get broken because he was resisting arrest,
fighting, interrupting a
What do you Yeah, Hasan didn't want didn't wish like PTSD on
a random veteran or all veterans. He literally went to a veteran
who's talking [__] in his chat, and he talked some
[__] back.
Isn't that just [__] around and find
Why does Asmongold only believe in [__] around and
find out when it's Israel getting hit?
Very interesting.
More insight into the mind of Okay, we're getting We're getting
in there. We're digging around. We're seeing what's going on.
interrupting an event. Like, you can't have Like, listen, inside
of Maybe Hasan doesn't know this, right? But inside of a civilized
Western society, you can't have a bunch of people that are in
the crowd of an event that just whenever they hear something
that makes them mad, they just get up out of their chair and
start yelling. Like, you can't have that happen. I don't know
if he knows this or not. I mean, I know like, you know, he was
in the US for He was born in the US. He didn't grow up in the
US. Maybe he might not picked up on this. But like,
Yeah, I think everybody agrees with you. Everybody agrees with
that guy being removed. It's just like if that guy's holding
onto the door, you might want to make sure that you're not going
to like shatter his arm. That's all. That's all. It's just like,
"Hey, we could We do this in a bit more of a controlled way.
We could get more help. We could move him out slowly, right?"
It wasn't like imperative that that should get fixed immediately.
>> You know, I don't think he went to school here. It's
like in school here, we learn like you don't just in whenever
you're mad at the teacher, you don't just get up and start yelling,
right? You don't do that. So, it's not how it works. So, I didn't
want him to get his arm broken cuz he was a veteran. Dude,
I I don't know how to explain this.
Civil disobedience is just that. You are disobeying
civil procedure, whatever the normal civil functioning society
is. You are disobeying. You are trying to actually cause some
uh like some level of I don't know
not harassment. You're trying to cause like inconvenience to
other people. You're trying to inconvenience things. So, you're
not using force, so you're not using anything that's like destructive.
You're just trying to inconvenience other people to make a point
about some issue. That's what civil disobedience is.
The penalty for seri- The penalty for civil disobedience shouldn't
be physical assault. >> And the difference obviously with
this and and that is that Hasan is now comparing that to him
wanting a veteran to get PTSD for Or Sorry, I'm saying physical
assault. Like, I guess having like an actual injury inflicted
on you. You can move somebody out. That's fine. That's okay.
Just don't have to break the arm. >> that they are a veteran,
right? So, like whenever a veteran does something bad, then you
obviously think like, "Oh yeah, well, this guy's a dumbass."
That doesn't mean that you're attacking them for being a veteran.
That's like saying that like a veteran can't be a criminal. Like,
obviously they can be. Like, does it does that mean you want
to put veterans in jail because there's a veteran that's a criminal
that should be in jail? No, of course not. Like this is like
one-dimensional. I don't know why anybody would even say this.
Yeah, based. And then he just >> I I'll be honest. I was
resetting the timer right there. >> I'm going to listen
to that whole thing again and see if that made any sense cuz
it he said it like it was he was making a good point. And then
I'm like I just reset the timer and I wasn't really paying attention
for a second. >> That doesn't mean that you're attacking
him for being a veteran. That's like saying that like a veteran
can't be a criminal. Like obviously they can be. Like does it
does that mean you want to put veterans in jail because there's
a veteran that's a criminal that should be in jail? No, of course
not. Like this is like one I get what he's saying that like it
wasn't along the lines of the identity that he attacked the guy.
That's what he's saying. And that's a fine response.
But then the next thing he said is just >> I don't know
why anybody would even say this. Yeah, based. And that he deserved
it. And he's been sitting on this for a while, I see. Which literally
doesn't say a single damn thing about that but then turns around
and tries to ban
I don't think Hasan's not necessarily making like a a good point.
I just like pointing out that Hasan Gold is totally psyched about
somebody getting their arm broken for protesting Israel. I just
like reinforcing that to people all the time. Basically. >> [__]
[__] this >> he's preemptively getting mad
at something that hasn't even happened. He's like pre-molding,
right? It's like you've got something going on and you
Like you have this like so it it didn't even happen nothing even
happened. He's still getting himself mad.
platform. I will never come back here. I will wait. >> Y'all
are a bunch what is this Karen stuff? Like >> for this
this platform. I will never come back
>> What why? Like I will say
I don't know if Hasan wants to commit to that necessarily. Does
he want to commit to that, really? I don't know. That's [clears throat]
We'll see.
>> We'll see. Okay.
Y'all are a bunch of dumb too for being like you're going to
get
Well, you you did. I mean to be I mean to be fair, they were
right.
actually couldn't agree more with Hasan right there, okay? Now
Hasan is good. When you are sitting in the chat, you're like
you're going to get banned for that. Hey, do you know that you're
going to get banned for that? Do you know that you could get
banned for that? I think you could get banned for that. You should
you you might get banned for that. You shouldn't have done the
thing that'll get you banned. You just broke the TOS. You just
broke the TOS. You just broke the TOS. You just broke the Shut
up. Actually, like do you understand that you're not helping
by doing that in the chat? You're making things worse for the
streamer. Like you are actually a total And most people don't
realize they're being complete morons when they do it. But but
like you should realize that like when you do that. Hey, you're
just you're breaking the TOS. You're breaking the TOS. You're
breaking the TOS. You're going to get banned. You're going to
get banned. You're going to get banned. You you're a real You're
like a total f- Okay? Just letting you know. You are basically
for anybody who wasn't paying attention who might have missed
it, you're basically saying guys, just in case you were hate
watching, know that you could go report. Know that to check the
VOD and go report. Make sure if you were hate watching, if you
like hate this guy, you should go check the VOD and report
That's what you're doing at that moment, okay? It's annoying.
>> I mean just just so we're we're keeping score here.
They were right. He did get clipped.
That's what we're watching right now. Yes. Dumb
Doesn't even realize his own lived experiences should have taught
him a very valuable lesson. Maybe they did.
Ever think of that? Maybe going up against ISIS and Al-Qaeda
for like years is going to make somebody more negative towards
Islam. I mean I think that's a pretty it's pretty reasonable
expectation to have, right? Like I would assume that, sure. How
[__] get banned for telling his followers to buy
bomb drone materials? He didn't say anything wrong in that clip.
This one I mean like I don't know if they're going to ban him
for this or not. It'll look pretty weird if he said that like,
you know, enjoy your PTSD
and it's like, you know, he doesn't get in trouble for that cuz
they banned Frogan for the same thing. And I guess we'll just
have to wait and see what Twitch does. I mean who knows? I mean
like I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I
I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I
I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I >> And
uh it's not the West about before Islam before his family went
back to Turkey. I don't think a lot of his family's in America.
I some of it is, some of it isn't. I have no idea. So yeah, what
a what a what a bad time for him. And really having a bad time.
Very very upset. Now why is he mad about this? I really don't
know. I mean I I I have no idea. I think that Hasan is just he's
very overly defensive about Islam and I don't really know why
and I think that you know, it's just it's one of those things
where like is the moment somebody criticizes that I mean the
weird thing is that I'm sure that like if I had said some of
the things that the Islamic country leaders, like the guys in
the UAE and Qatar have talked about and said about Islam, if
I had just simply taken their quotes and said them myself, I'm
sure he'd probably call me Islamophobic, too. The fact
What? No. >> is that, you know, again, like this isn't
a religion thing necessarily, but I think that there's very obviously
a correlation that Islamic terrorism is happening at a very very
high ratio not only in Western countries but What? Dude, Islamic
terrorism so you can't you have to have it be motivated by the
faith, right? Like Islamic terrorism was a thing. It has not
been a thing in Western countries for a very long time. There
aren't like or I don't [clears throat] know. Maybe maybe countries
just gotten way better at defending against it. I don't know.
But like the whole splinter cell, you know, doing a lone wolf
attack or whatever, that [__] has been happening
for a long time. Am I crazy?
I feel like ideologically motivated Islamic terrorism has stopped
in relation to where it was 8 years ago. 8 to 10 years ago that
[__] seemed to be popping off a lot, right?
And now I I just don't see it anymore. >> Islamic countries
as well. And to ignore that and to pretend like that's not happening
is Uh maybe in Europe, but in America in Canada, America, I don't
see that [__] a lot. is I think ridiculous and I
think that the amount of times like people will never be able
people will never come to terms with with like the cognitive
dissonance of looking at, you know, a very obvious a very obvious
pattern. Like this is an obvious pattern that like every single
person, every adult can see. Every even teenager or child can
see. Why is it that every person that's like committing these
terrorist attacks seems to be, you know, of this group, right?
It's pretty obvious. And it's the same thing that they say about
white guys being school shooters. And you know, like that's it.
So what's up, man? Yeah, I'm just saying in general. this is
really the radical Islamist criminal ideology. It is. So yeah,
don't believe your lying eyes. You you see 50 different collabor
corroborations, but for some reason you know, there's no no
Dan responded to me. He said you moved on from Destiny, I can
move on from
I let him know that Destiny's just boring. That's why I don't
cover him. But when he's not boring, I do. So Dan, you could
do it. Dan, you could do it. Dan! Hasan's Hasan's shown his ass.
Dan, you could get him this time. I believe in you, Dan. One
more run. One more time, okay?
You got to get the band back together. You one more Hasan is
bad tour, okay? One more time. YOU CAN YOU'LL GET HIM THIS TIME.
>> this at all. I think he's overly defensive in general.
Yeah, I mean I would I don't I I could see him getting banned
for this. I mean maybe maybe not, right? And I also think that
if he does get banned, he's not he's not going to leave Twitch.
If he goes to YouTube and then his YouTube streams start declining
and his influence goes down, then he's going to probably come
back to Twitch because that's what he You think that's likely
though? Like I don't think I don't think Hasan Gold believes
that's likely, right?
The only problem Hasan might have on YouTube is he'll have to
figure out how he's going to basically take react content and
make sure it's like still good on YouTube.
I think that's the only concern he would have, right? Is basically
he reacts to a lot of stuff. Can he react to all of the same
things on YouTube without getting his streams clapped? He cares
about. He cares about having influence and he'll always make
the decision that's in the best interest of that. I think so.
And I guess we'll find out, right? I mean we'll find out if he
gets banned. But you know, probability that Hasan gets like a
7-day ban or a 3-day ban for this and then, you know, afterwards
he you know, like a
you know, like he he he he comes back to Twitch. I think that
the probability is going 100%. Maybe we can do a Polymarket event
on it, right? Is I I think Hasan Gold's actually correct here.
I think if if Hasan gets banned, he's actually leaving. He's
not actually going anywhere. Come on. Come on. If Hasan gets
banned, he's going back to Twitch. He's not he's not just going
to stop streaming there entirely.
Right? I don't think so. >> back Maybe he'll take like
a couple days off in protest. to Twitch, right? I think it's
so obvious it will happen. Uh maybe it's not the religion but
it's the desperation from the scarcity in the countries that
are mostly Muslim. Well, I don't think I think that that that
that that falls apart whenever you look at Muslims that are like
the two guys the other day in New York who grew up in multi-million
dollar houses, right? I mean I think that like you're right that
socio-economic and environmental factors play a big part in like
why somebody does something. I think that's very true. But at
the same time, I think that it's a confluence of events, right?
It's not like one thing. It's like five things. And one of those
things is religious. That doesn't mean that all five of them
are, but one of them certainly is. And I I'm sorry. If they if
these people grew up in multi-million dollar households in New
York City,
I don't believe that they're significantly religious. I just
don't. I'm sorry. I don't. It's probably not a factor at all.
I just statistically, it's probably not a factor whatsoever.
>> And you should think about that. So
And that's definitely ideology. Well, there's not really a reason
for it to be like it it doesn't have to be mutually exclusive
is what my point is. So yeah. And is it liberals that with Ayatollah
all about spread that type of ideology. Oh, I think it's embarrassing.
It is. And so so if Islam is doing all the problems around the
world and you understand this is Islamic problem, why when it
comes to Israel is it suddenly the fault? I don't blame everything
on I there have actually been people that are angry at Ooh, hold
on.
This is where another of our Asmongold clips comes up. Interesting.
He's uh interesting interesting >> Islam is doing all the
problems around the world and you understand this is Islamic
problem, why when it comes to Israel is it suddenly the fault?
I don't blame everything on the I there have actually been people
that are angry at me for not doing that. People have been very
mad. They've been saying why um Asmongold
something bad happened.
Why haven't you named the >> Oh, he's going to totally
Okay, I see. He's going to totally like misrepresent the criticism
he gets. He's He's having a Pirate Software moment on this one.
There's nobody that you're taking seriously and it's not the
meat or or lion's share of the criticism that people like name
the Asmongold, talk about world right now Asmongold. Nobody's
doing that. Come on. It's hey, you're America first. This war
was clearly at the behest of Israel. They've been pushing for
it for a long time. You've got a senator going to Israel and
getting intelligence from Mossad that the US doesn't give him,
right? And then going back and trying to convince Trump to go
and hit Iran.
off Oh, that's If I could If I called that out and said it was
like Israel's war, that would be like naming the No, it wouldn't.
It would just be you being honest. But you're incapable. >> You
Listen Listen There's literally
a tragedy
and you haven't Fun fact, he banned the word from his kick chat.
No
at banned from his kick chat. There's no
No shot. Mentioned once. How Oh, hold on. You Listen Listen There's
literally a tragedy
and you haven't >> Oh, wait. True True True True. Auto
AI the AI automod bans Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. That's what it
is. That's what it is.
You can't We We can't do it here either and we love that. once
How much did they pay you?
How much? How much was it? It's got to be more than $7,000
hours. Totally totally fabricating the thing. Okay. It's so gay.
It's so It's so annoying, right? That he'll go and he'll take
legitimate criticism that this doesn't make sense. Dude, you
were the guy who didn't want wars. You defended the Venezuela
thing based on it not being protracted and prolonged and not
being something that affected Americans negatively. This action
has unequivocally already hurt
Why? Why was it done? It wasn't done and I don't believe we can
go back and watch all of his reactions. There's no way you can
defend that this was in America's interest. It wasn't in the
average American's interest whatsoever.
Not even a little bit. Okay? And so you claim to be America first.
We'll watch a clip later where he says he agrees with everything.
Like almost everything with Nick Fuentes. I agree with Nick on
so much. I agree with him on almost
Uh that can't be true cuz this is sort of a foundational thing.
It's like telling me you're like you're you're you know you murdered
somebody and you're like Of course I'm a Christian. Why would
I Why would I There's something It's like you're doing something
that is essentially totally against the other person's ethos
entirely and then saying you agree with them on most things.
So you can't. The thing you're doing is actually totally incompatible
with the way that person views the world.
I'm trying to think of like a good analogy for it. I can't off
the top of my head, but it is totally incompatible. We'll keep
going. You know Yeah, why exactly? And that's it. Of course.
And you see Iran striking What is this here? Iran striking Turkey
a third time? No, I didn't see that. What the hell is wrong with
them? No, I didn't see that at all. I'll look at it. I mean obviously
I'm just kind of you know, looking at this stuff for the first
time today. After Iran's latest ballistic missile strikes on
central Israel. Oh, so this is I guess this is one of the missiles.
This is in Israel. Maybe, right? I mean Okay, that's it. That's
it for the Asmongold coverage. Okay. We can go to the Hutch coverage
now and then I'm looking for other reactions from other people
if there's other funny stuff. I did see Dickers tweeted this
one out. This one seemed like it could be funny. Give me a second.
What is this? Twitch, I'm uploading this to start a formal report
on Hasan the Hun. Veteran discrimination is unacceptable even
from a millionaire turd like Hasan, terrorist, dog abuser, brothel
[__] Wow. So what a cool guy, Kodiak VT.
Wow. What a cool guy.
You come back from Iraq and you talk about how this was actually
awesome and I hate Islam. Then you you didn't learn anything.
You're I'm going to make you my personal mission, Hasan.
I'm going to make you my mission.
>> I want to get to the Hutch thing cuz I do think it'll
be funny. I've heard I've heard it's very funny. All right.
Hutch can't resist, man.
Hutch cannot resist. See what? Maybe.
Uh Hasan says enjoy PTSD to a veteran. Oh my god.
Are you kidding me with that? There's no way he actually said
that, right? There's no way he actually said that,
What What? There's no There's no way.
What? That's totally Bro, cue cue the Hasan highlight reel. Talk
about Dan Talk about Dan Crenshaw getting hit in his eye hole.
>> There's no way he said enjoy PTSD.
That's totally incompatible with like what Hasan believes and
would ever say. That's like crazy.
What? There's no way he actually said that, right? 15 years out
from Iraq, eat my balls.
Do you even have your balls remaining or did a IED explode them
for you, dumbass? Oh my god. Soy Soy Oh my god.
Did he really just
Did he really just Wow.
Wow.
This one's going to follow him for a while, you guys. That is
a wild thing to say. Wow. Wow.
Observational humor. This guy said he's a veteran. You say something
that you think is funny about veterans. Definitely crazy. By
the way, nobody soy out about this part. Everybody's like oh
yeah, that's just totally within bounds unfortunately, right?
I D Yeah, exactly. I D'ing on Maine?
Wow. Wow. Wow. That is a crazy thing to say. I you know, what
like one of my bro, like one of my best friends died from a IED.
Like
>> The Sorry. That's not strictly
Sorry. That's not I I have to control myself.
I'm sorry. That is actually tremendously funny. There's no way
he just There's no way. There's no way he just did that. There's
no way that he Sorry. I was not prepared. I was not prepared.
I was not prepared.
I was not ready. I'm sorry. Dude, that's
Why doesn't Hasan think about all the people who suffered in
Iraq?
Why doesn't he think about the people who suffered? Why doesn't
he think about it? Oh.
Wow. This one's going to follow him for a while, you guys. That
is a wild thing to say. Hold on. Hold on. Somebody needs to Somebody
needs to Photoshop the Boruto fans talking to Chibi Reviews about
his brother. Okay?
All right. That's all I'm going to say. Somebody needs to Photoshop
and and rework those tweets and Okay. Thank you. Thank you. That's
all we can say.
bro, like one of my best friends died from a IED. Like That is
a wild thing to say, man. Oh man, shut the up talking about Islam.
You are an infinitely
Seems like we should pretty easily oppose the war then. This
war that's being undertaken not for the benefit of any American.
What has Hutch been saying about the war? Has he talked very
much about how he feels about it? Like what are his problems
with it?
I actually don't know what his problems with it are. I would
love to know cuz I
I do think that sort of personal experience should lead you to
opposing this like very strongly. And I'm not sure I've seen
any clips, but I might not see clips of Hutch thinking about
>> And what like one of my
come on, man. Come on, man. Come on, man. Come on, man. be bigger
terrorist than any random Muslim ever could be. dumbass [__]
up. Shut your ass up. Go enjoy your PTSD ass. He cut all of the
war talk out of his straight raid video. Uh-huh.
Bro, I just Man, that straight raid talk is still funny.
I don't know. I don't know if Hutch really appreciates anything
that was actually going on in that talk, which is kind of funny
to me as well.
Oh no, he I bet you anything he knew he up when he said that.
That's a crazy thing to say.
That's a crazy thing to say. He's I I That's kind of crazy, man.
Is it?
I I'll bet you anything a lot of politicians are going to
As opposed to
I I think like Hasan doesn't realize that people are going to
clip that and then politicians are going to call for him to be
banned and they're going to totally freak out about it. It's
like yeah, I think that's called Tuesday for
No? Is that not just Tuesday at this point? Like hey yeah, a
whole bunch of politicians are going to soy out and say this
Hasan [__] guy's got to go. Yeah, I think I've heard
that one before actually. Pretty sure I've heard it. to collaborate
with him now. I don't know. It's just just from a practical perspective,
not even setting aside the morality of it, but just practically
if he he's obviously looking to expand his reach and make connections
and you know, and collaborate with politicians and he's been
doing that more Hmm, that's an interesting if Hutch wanted to
take that angle, that would be the angle you take, right? Oh,
oh, why would these politicians talk to a guy who said he hopes
a veteran gets PTSD?
Why would he do that? I I you could probably hurt him that way.
I think there's a line if you just totally disingenuously want
to hurt the guy,
but then if if Hutch wants to go that way, just keep track of
the people cuz if they want to go that way,
like you have friends that I know you probably want to reintroduce
into, you know, mainstream political discourse, talking and collabing
with people. Like
should they be doing it? If that if that statement's way out
of line for Hassan,
right? I just I would love to know how that's going to go on
the other side when somebody closer to Hutch who he likes and
respects and collabs with pretty consistently now, you know,
gets that same standard applied to them. I feel like he's not
going to like it but maybe not. But saying stuff like that, that
will make you so toxic. I can't believe he said that. I can't
believe he said that. Again, we should probably keep track of
the difference between the Frogan statement and the Hassan statement,
right? Hassan statement is to a specific guy who is being racist
and Islamophobic in his chat, right? A specific guy who's talking
about this. And then who asked, brother, who the [__]
asked?
Who asked?
asked? Sorry, I
I just I okay, all right.
This is
This is one of those things where it's like I get it and it's
hard if you're really upset with somebody in the moment not to
use some sort of identity like a some sort of identity attack
on them, especially when you don't know anything about them,
right? This guy, the only thing Hassan knows about this guy is
that he's a veteran and he's Islamophobic. He's going to put
those two things together and say something to insult him. It's
pretty obvious where that goes,
I think if you're one of the people who hears that and you think
Hassan is saying I hope all veterans get PTSD or he's talking
about you, I just think that's probably inappropriate but I understand
I would if I if that person wasn't in a Hutch chatter, I'd have
a lot of empathy for them, okay? I cannot believe he said that.
Personally. I'm having difficulty processing that he said that.
Imagine having the audacity to be like, yeah, I went to Iraq.
I went to Iraq and it's actually Islam that's the biggest danger.
You're the danger, idiot.
It's so woke 1.0, just zero sticking value, obviously snark coded.
Yeah, I agree with that analysis mostly.
That I mean I do think the point Hutch wants to make or the point
Hutch made there that like this could affect Hassan politically
like having mainstream collaborations, I do think there's something
to that but You're a danger to your family.
What the Oh, did he get that? Oh, Asmongold missed that, eh?
Right? We We know that Asmongold just totally missed that.
cuz those are probably the worst statements, right? To me, when
you say that, that's like basically you have a trans person in
your chat and you're like, hey, you're a danger to yourself.
You're referencing the uh this this statistics, right? Like we
all understand in that case why somebody would get banned for
that. Did Asmon get it? Okay, all right. What the I didn't get
that. Isn't it against TOS?
There you go. That's a tweet right there. Wild, you guys.
And a danger to yourself, douchebag. Dude, this is worth it just
to watch Hutch soy at these like basic >> Oh man, I'm
Oh my god, you guys. >> Oh, that's getting clipped on my
own. This guy is so goofy, man. Oh man, I'm
own. I don't give a [__] dude. Shut the [__]
up. If you go to Iraq and you learn that lesson, you realize
that that was wrong, you're welcome here. You come back from
Iraq and you [__] talk about how this was actually
awesome and I [__] hate Islam, then [__]
you. You didn't learn anything. You're goddamn cattle. You're
sending other That This is like the only There must be analysis
that comes up at some point, right?
Like to just say that's wild and and make a soy face and do zero
talking, you're just on your phone. I assume he's
But like that can't be the stream. >> like you Well, what
did the guy actually say? Hang on. Oh, is he going to get the
Cuz he Well, no, he couldn't be tweeting yet because a part of
the tweet was him saying, well, the guy was actually really out
of line, too. Well, to be fair, the guy the guy he's he's interacting
with is kind of wilding out about um Islam.
But nonetheless, you know, you still don't say [__]
like that. Oh, the person who was posting that I mean you don't
have confirmation but they implied they were a veteran, right?
They said I'm 15 years out from Iraq or something like
Like they they do imply strongly they're a veteran. >> this
is that like you know, nothing justifies that, right? >> You're
goddamn cattle. You're sending other people like you to be in
a similar predicament to yourself. Whatever, [__]
I'll start livestreaming on YouTube tomorrow. Suck my dick. Now
you're getting clipped. By who? The people that have been literally
begging for American sons and daughters to go and die in Iran
for the last 2 weeks. By people Uh Twitch's strictest rules apply
when speech targets protected characteristics such as There's
no way he's got ChatGPT open.
He must No, no, no. He's got That's got to be the actual Twitch
TOS, right? gender identities, orientation, disability, nationality.
Veteran or military service is not listed as protected characteristic
so insults towards veterans aren't classified as hateful conduct.
Um it still may violate Twitch's harassment, abuse, abusive con
It's definitely in the TOS that veterans are a protected class
under one of their harassment policies, for sure.
>> Is it just chat Didn't they I thought they passed a
new TOS
policy because of the Frogan thing. That is for sure TOS. I mean
this is for sure TOS. This is for sure TOS. People who keep going,
yeah, based. No, we got to give more money to Israel.
Those people those people who are going to turn around and then
now act as though they give a [__] about veterans?
The same people like Asmongold who celebrated when that Navy
SEAL
Hutch, it's listed. Oh my god. What? Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. All
right, ChatGPT got it wrong again, guys. There you go. There's
no way There's no way that Hutch's content is literally him pausing
a video
and silently looking at his phone while he looks something up
on ChatGPT on his
That's not Did this guy gets like a thousand concurrence?
Like a thousand concurrence.
It's actual
Yo, you beat ChatGPT. Twitch aims to be Oh, this is their hateful
conduct policy. I see. Oh, no, they added it. Yeah, for sure.
Veteran right there. Twitch aims to be a place where everyone
can come together and share community experiences. Vision is
threatened when people experience harmful rhetoric and abuse
on Twitch. Twitch does not permit behavior that is motivated
by a hatred, prejudice or intolerance including behavior that
promotes or encourages discrimination, denigration, harassment
or violence based on the following protected characteristics:
race, ethnicity, color, cast,
national origin, immigration It does kind of feel like he
like unquestionably violated the TOS. It's just so gay that people
signal about it in this way. And nobody nobody really believes
that that should be like how the TOS is enforced. And they'll
all say as much a lot of times when they actually talk about
it, they'll say like, well, I wish the TOS wasn't that way but
it is that way so they should get banned. >> status, religion,
gender, gender identities, orientation, disability, serious medical
condition, that's another one right there, PTSD, and veteran
status. >> uh with his with his uniform had his arm broken.
Really? I mean to be to be clear, the guy the guy that he pulled
up was wilding out about about um Islam but you know why is every
other veteran catching strays here? You know what I mean? That's
just such a I my brain went to inappropriate but that's not that
doesn't cover it. I mean this is such this is such an this is
such an unacceptable thing to say, man. You don't like that's
unbelievable.
It's unbelievable.
Mhm. You know, a lot of the a lot of the people that signed up
for the military like my I
my buddy >> Ah, I won't. >> May he rest in peace.
Oh, hold on. Referencing the dead buddy again? You know, a lot
of the a lot of the people that signed up for the military like
my may he rest in peace. He did that I I you know, he did that
mostly because he was lacking direction
and uh was struggling in school. Like he was he was such a smart
guy but he was never a good student. And uh you know, he needed
he needed the GI bill. Like he needed he needed that [__]
And uh
he didn't sign up because he wanted to go over there and like
[__] other people. Many many such cases. Many such
cases as far as people that sign up for the military so I Okay,
I Yeah. Do you think if your buddy came back, he would hate all
Arabs? >> This is such an outrageous thing to say. That's
what we're doing? If Twitch can apply this double standard when
one veteran is getting their arm broken by an American congressperson
for opposing America waging Israel's wars, when Twitch doesn't
ban Asmongold for laughing at that and saying Hold on. I'm following
the the right eyebrow of Hutch here. That's what I'm looking
at, okay? >> American congressperson for opposing America
waging Israel's wars, when Twitch doesn't ban Asmongold for laughing
at that and I don't know what to think about this sometimes.
Can I Hold on. Can I find this? I
Hutch's right eyebrow fascinates me, okay? It it does fascinate
me. I am obsessed with Hutch, by the way. So if you didn't think
so, if you didn't realize, yes, I am actually obsessed.
Okay, I am.
This is Hutch waiting to speak while Soy Pill is speaking in
his call. He's not
This is just him chilling in a call waiting for Soy Pill to stop
talking so he could talk.
What what What is going on here? It's just it's very interesting
to me. >> And that he deserved it. When Twitch literally
doesn't say a single damn thing about that but then turns around
and tries to Well, did Asmon like
do targeted harassment against veterans?
Or did he just I mean I don't Listen, I I obviously don't Asmon.
But it's entirely possible that what he what Asmon said in that
clip, whatever he's referring to, was um extremely distasteful
and disgusting but not technically a violation of TOS, right?
Oh my god, Hassan talking about a I mean I think glorifying violence
is basically always TOS unfriendly.
But Asmongold breaks the TOS all the time, right? Which double
standard is just so [__] funny. Yeah, yeah, for
It is on due targeted harassments towards vets. It depends on
the language. I could go read the we could go through the TOS
man NLT. Hassan absolutely like saw the guy being Islamophobic,
saw the guy say he was a veteran and went okay.
You're Islamophobic and you're veteran. You just came back from
Iraq. Here's how I'm going to [__] with you, right?
Hassan is using that status that the protected status against
the guy. Going to say statistics stereotypes about that status,
right? Your your family isn't safe with you. You're not safe
with you,
So I would say it probably falls under the TOS. It's just like
Unfortunately,
I feel like this should be allowed purely on the basis that it's
hard to talk [__] to no name chatters, okay? They
come in, they know everything about you. They're going to [__]
talk. How am I supposed to not be racist? That might be one of
only the only piece of information I have about you or you know,
prejudice based on your veteran
That's the only thing I know. That's the only weapon I have.
What the [__] ban me for this this platform. I will
never come back here. Y'all are a bunch Yes, he will. Yes, he
will. bunch of dumb [__] too for being like, "Oh,
you're going to get clipped." So out of bounds. Dumb
doesn't even realize his own lived experiences should have taught
him a very valuable lesson. What the [__] do you
know about his life experience, man?
What the [__] What can you How could you possibly
I mean, I'm sorry. The the life experiences that guy went to
Iraq 15 years ago
and then was Islamophobic in in Hassan's chat. I
What whatever life experience led you to be defending essentially
the idea of going to Iran and then you coming in and just being
like openly Islamophobic in his chat. Hassan doesn't respect
that. Obvious. You know, sometimes, man, people just don't know
how to turn that [__] off and are prone to kind of
self-sabotage.
15 years out from Iraq, eat my balls. Okay. I we got a quartering
reaction after this. This is going to be funny, I think. I believe
Hutch is now writing the tweet. wild wild
You're not And then he's back to you marathon. Very cool. All
right.
Now there's a quartering reaction, okay?
Ban Hassan forever for this is totally reasonable, I guess.
The quartering wants Hassan banned
Because Hassan wants to go to YouTube. He's leaving Twitch with
a bang.
Like an improvised explosive device. He is going out with a bang.
Yes, Lily I think that's possible that he wants to be, you know,
off of Twitch onto YouTube. Yeah, I think that's It seems reasonable
to me that he would want that. But
yeah, I don't know.
I I think he'll still keep it running, right? He probably doesn't
want to get permabanned. I this I don't think he's at risk of
that, though. care having a big melty.
So a veteran
called out Hassan and he goes absolutely
bonkers saying a bunch of stuff that we know he would never ever
say to this guy's face. I guarantee it. 15 years out from Iraq,
eat my balls.
Wow, Hassan would never say that to this veteran's face.
Why would you ever say something on the internet that you wouldn't
say to somebody's face? What are you like a keyboard warrior
or something?
What are you like a You're like a keyboard warrior. Like you
say things on the internet that you wouldn't say in real life?
No way.
Do you even have your balls remaining? My uh by the way, my my
chat overlay thing is totally the thing that combines. I can't
see chat at all. I can barely like you guys aren't coming through
for me on chat. I got to open up a different window. Give me
a second. 15 years out from Iraq, eat my balls.
Do you even have your balls remaining or did a [__]
IED explode them for you, dumbass? Shut the Oh, here we go. Here
we go with another This is a Hassan's
big America deserved
September 11th moment again. This guy's unhinged.
There are legitimate criticisms to have, you know, about certain
foreign countries, but people like Hassan and the people on the
other side of that way way far the other side of that have made
it completely
Uh this guy gets so triggered
[__] up talking about Islam.
I mean, Hassan does think America deserved 9/11 spiritually,
okay? Like some retribution for their acts in the Arab world,
but
I don't know if that's what this is. This is like just somebody
talking [__] How is everybody reading like more into
this? How do you read like so much into something? Guy gave me
two piece of information. He hates Arabs and he was in Iraq.
Yeah, this is This is just the line you'd go down to talk [__]
back. He's an entertainer. It's entertainment.
What's
You are an infinitely bigger terrorist than any random Muslim
ever could be. Oh, really?
You don't know What if he was uh in a What if What if he was
in Iraq serving food in the mess hall?
Would you Would you I mean, this guy would never talk like that.
Oh, he's he's paused shaming here, okay? He's he's paused too
early. Hassan says you're a bigger terrorist because you are
a due to your PTSD, you're a threat to your family and yourself.
That's what Hassan's going for here. He's just paused too early.
He's not going to appreciate the joke. He's going to lose the
context from the first statement when it goes to the second statement,
okay? to any US veteran. Like Too bad. There he would never ever
ever talk like that. There's there's just it is, you know, it
is so wild to me that this guy feels so comfortable being such
an
Shut your face up. Oh. your [__] PTSD
You Imagine Go enjoy your PTSD.
Now a much smaller creator, an egg-shaped one, famously went
viral
bro for wishing We got to talk about
Don't go after the egg when you're a pear, okay? That's [__]
up.
How are you going to Dude, you going to hit Frogan on being fat
as the quartering PTSD on American soldiers.
Um and she now streams for about seven people in complete obscurity
having mental breakdowns every night every show
She should Dude. What the [__] Are we just going
to get concentrated mirror posting right now? Just totally concentrated
mirror posting.
That's crazy. That's actually [__]
Isn't this the guy who consistently begs for money, makes horrible
financial decisions and pawns them off on his community all the
time?
What? been smart and started a delicious coffee company that
people could get at
but uh her moment in the sun came and went and now Hassan [__]
seems like he's ready to completely melt down and burn it all
down, too, which I'm happy to watch. And having the audacity
to just be like, "Yeah, I went to Iraq. I went to Iraq and it's
actually Islam that's the biggest danger. You're the danger."
Hold Let's look at the quartering uh 2024 June 2024 and then
it's just been a steady
steady steady downward spiral for him. Okay, very cool.
Very cool. Just more mirror posting. I'm happy Hassan's going
to burn it all down. Dude, he's he's just losing it, guys. I'm
like I'm enjoying watching the end of his career, for sure. Wow.
And you're idiot.
>> what was the religion of the last Somebody sent me the
tweets, okay? Somebody sent me the tweet right now of this guy
basically like trying to [__] Melanie Mac at that
No, wait. Was it Melanie Mac? It was Melanie Mac and then the
girl who used to be on Tim Pool, right? It was those two were
sitting with him at like some conference and he's like clearly
talking about hanging out later.
And you see how awkward it is. I need that clip. last four people.
These last four attacks that happened in the last
Could there have been a
a connecting fact for them like a connector? Was there something
that made them all kind of similar? Uh
is it possible?
Um maybe. You're a danger to your family.
And a danger to yourself. douchebag
Well, that's getting clipped, Lamar. I don't give a dude Shut
the [__] up. If you go to Iraq and you learn that
lesson, you re- Yeah, see? He's going to lose that the context
from before. He's going to totally [__] up. Which
should be That should be where people freak out.
if you're going to be like a a woke about somebody being, you
know, prejudice, that's where you should freak out. And he just
is a total cattle.
This guy is another, you know, another actual beef, man. He's
just cattle. He's There's nothing going on here. There's no light
behind the eyes.
He He rushed to get this out, didn't actually contemplate what
was being
There's just nothing going on here. It's a very sad existence.
realize that that was wrong, you're welcome here. You call Oh,
we have the Turkish guy, the Turkish nep- nepo baby telling US
American soldiers whether they're welcome or not. Wait, isn't
he just talking about it in his chat? Hold learn that lesson,
you realize that that was wrong, you're welcome here. You call
Oh, we have the Turkish guy, the Turkish nep- nepo baby He's
definitely just talking about his chat. US American soldiers
whether they're welcome or not.
I don't know if he means in this country or his chat. But you
look at his chat. Get his Get him. Get him. Get him. You all
this kind of stuff. Hold on. Let's see what this kind of stuff
is. I like when Hassan says shut your ass up. I'm going to start
using that. Who gives a Somebody demented people we live amongst.
No, Hassan, you don't understand. This is just criticism of Islam.
Here we go. Get his ass. Get him. We went to Iraq over lies.
Broke killed people over a Chevy Tahoe, but thinks all Muslims
are itching to kill
Statistically,
uh yeah, apparently this is really bad. Wow. I like when Hassan
says shut your your b a up. Like this guy thinks he's so tough
with his gym muscles and his Hollywood uh Hills mansion. I would
love for him to say that to American soldier that served in Iraq.
I would love for him to say it face-to-face. He won't though.
I'm back from Iraq and Okay. you [__] talk about
how this was a Could you imagine Could you imagine going on the
internet and saying things you wouldn't say in real life? I can't
imagine, guys. actually awesome and I Hey, Islam. Then [__]
you. You didn't learn anything. You're cattle. You're sending
other people like you to be in a similar predicament to yourself.
Whatever. I'll start live streaming on YouTube tomorrow. Suck
my Now, he's so he's he's really worried now about getting banned
by Twitch for saying enjoy your PTSD, which is something that
Twitch. The The analysis is awful. Terrible terrible stuff. Let's
watch this, okay?
At the Quartering, your cringey manchild creep, so and so are
the people who listen to you. You can clearly see Melanie Mac
look at the other chick and whisper, "Help me." when you're trying
to force her to go watch football with you. Aren't you married?
Yeah. Um Melanie and I will be watching the football game tonight
and Hannah Claire will probably be going somewhere family orientated.
I can't watch football with you guys? You can. I would love that.
Oh yeah, that would be fun. Wow, thanks, Melanie. I would love
it. Yeah. We just didn't know if you wanted to, but I would love
it. I'm great at watching sports and by that I mean I'm solidly
okay. Well, yeah. Well, we got to figure out where we're going
to go. I have a dinner place I want to go, but I got to call.
Okay. Um Um Yeah. Hold on. I missed the help me. What was it
here? Melanie and I will be watching the football game tonight
and uh Hannah Claire will probably be going so Right there. Right
there. >> going somewhere family Hold on. Hold on. Claire
will probably be going somewhere family They make eye contact.
I feel like this is all you needed to
Right? This is all you needed to see.
Oh, wait. I can't watch football with you guys? >> somewhere
family orientated. I can't watch football with you guys? You
can. I would love that. Oh Dude, how quickly she answers. What?
Oh yeah, that would
football with you guys? You can. I would love that. Oh yeah,
that would be fun. Hold on. Like there it's actually every frame
is literally a painting here, right? Like watch his reaction
to when she asks. He's like immediately he's like shrugging and
being like he doesn't want to commit to say yes. He's just like,
"Uh I don't know." Right? And she's like, "Yeah, that would be
awesome." You can. I would love that. Oh yeah, that would be
Wow, thanks, Melanie. I would love it. Yeah. We just didn't know
if you wanted to, but I would love it. I'm great at watching
sports and by that I mean I'm solidly okay. Well, yeah. Well,
we got to figure out where we're going to go. I have a dinner
place I want to go, but I got to call. Okay. Um Yeah.
Dude, it's actually so crazy, man.
Like this is so brutal on every level to have this clip to have
this happen. Why would you ever do this live on a stream?
Why would you be like talking
Yeah, I don't I actually don't know.
I How many times has she moved away? so uncomfortable. Um Melanie
and I will be watching the football game tonight and
Hannah Claire will probably be going somewhere family orientated.
I can't watch football with you guys? You can. I would love that.
Oh yeah, that would be fun. Wow, thanks, Melanie. I would love
it. Yeah. We just didn't know if you wanted to, but I would love
it. I'm great at watching sports and by that I mean I'm solidly
okay. Well, yeah. Well, we got to figure out This person probably
had plans. You said Well, there goes my Friday night.
Uh got to make sure that this woman doesn't get now, but thank
you. Thank you, Jeremy. Thank you.
I Yeah, I would love to watch football with you guys and just
make sure this woman doesn't get That would That's totally what
I want to do tonight. Thank you. Thank you. Fantastic. Okay.
Uh somebody had been previously banned at her baby with [laughter]
her. Dude, that's so awesome. That's so awesome because it just
makes it so much more obvious what's happening there that there's
no way she would just be like with her kid there, "Yeah, I want
to go watch a football game and drink with you guys and eat eat
eat like nachos and shit."
Nobody's doing that with a baby. Yeah, I'm going to bring my
baby over to the football game. Let's go, guys. and
on Twitch for that was Hold on. Wait wait wait. This is the cope
after he got called out. Let me check this out. In a complete
meltdown after being caught creeping on Melanie Mac despite being
married, the Quartering goes on an unhinged rant about how he
wasn't being a past because her breasts are too
There's no way There's no way he does the "She's not even my
type." She's like not even my Melanie Mac? She's like not even
my type, actually. There's no way. If you're in the chat worried
about where Melanie Mac is, stop being such a loser, you know?
What?
You guys know she's married
and she's on her honeymoon. So, if you're trying to like get
a response by being a degenerate piece of [__] like
know that she's my friend and uh it's not going to work.
I suppose it worked by getting me to say
I'm super pumped that we got that good pull on Pokémon because
the Pokémon openings have been a brutal.
Dude, I What? I Wait, how I'm actually super confused now. When
was this clip from? I thought it was months ago. Yeah, it's like
4 months ago, almost.
3 and 1/2 months ago.
And why
Wait, how is this complete meltdown of being caught creeping
on Melanie Mac despite being married, the Quartering goes on
an unhinged rant about how he wasn't being a K.
Why was Melanie Why was Melanie supposed to be on the show? Why
would people expect or why would they talk about this? It's not
like this would be the first time he streamed. What's There's
more context here that I'm missing.
Oh, it's only 4 months ago when the clip happened. So, she must
have been engaged. She's getting married. Are there other examples
of him creeping
that I've missed that I've never caught before? There's also
this like weird like Jeremy's friends with a girl, so he's definitely
trying to sleep with her
that is being per- perpetrated by only people who have never
been allowed around girls.
And uh I don't know what to tell you. You know, I'm friends with
a lot of girls and you're allowed to watch football with them
and be Oh, it's definitely about that. It's definitely about
that, for sure.
Oh, weird. >> and not be trying to sleep with them.
You guys all know I'm a boob guy,
It's like a a totally weird
fan fiction. Bro, I What is this thing
That That to me confirms that he was actually trying to [__]
her. Cuz I promise you I promise you that like after Dude, nobody
cares that much. Nobody Nobody's a big enough boob guy that if
they wanted to [__] somebody and they'd like have
small tits, they're just going to be like, "No, I don't want
to." There's no There's nothing like that. That doesn't That
doesn't exist in the world. Guys aren't like that. I'm sorry.
That's just total cope. That's total I like I like my I like
my you know, two scoops full.
All right. So, I love Melanie, but uh you know, I wouldn't even
cheat on my wife for you, Melanie.
Melanie, maybe if you could get like Maybe if you had surgery,
I'd think about cheating on my wife, okay? Guys, listen. There's
I would only cheat on my wife with someone with huge bolt-ons,
okay? That's That's the only way I cheat on my wife. >> No,
as a friend. >> Come on. I'm a Christian. It's easy to
She's great. She's a ride or die type of person. Do I think uh
Yeah, yeah, check it back with the content. Well, the last
thing I have to open right now is a another Lorwyn Eclipse booster
box with You can't get me with that, Jimberley. Nice try.
Nice try.
All right. Now, I am out. Unless there's more, I'm out of Hasan
Oh.
xQc
has begun reacting to the Hasan stuff. Now, let's see if that
random chatter that random guy in the comments of the one tweet
Let's see if that guy was correct. Let's see if he predicted
xQc being like completely incapable of having a like a sensical
sensible position on this. Do you even have your balls remaining
or did a IED explode them for you, dumbass? Shut the [__]
up talking about Islam. Wow, this is a crazy comment to make,
by the way. >> infinitely bigger terrorist than any random
Muslim ever could 15 years out from Iraq, eat my balls.
Do you even have your balls remaining or did a IED explode them
for you, dumbass? Shut the [__] up >> But,
Phil Overholt, you do support the channel and we do appreciate
you, so that we're going to let that one go, okay? We're going
to let that one go. talking about Islam. >> What the for
an infinitely bigger terrorist than any random Muslim ever could
be.
Shut your What's up? Go enjoy your PTSD at you. Imagine having
the audacity Okay, banned. Okay, banned. Okay, banned. So >> course
not going to get banned if I don't watch a clip and it doesn't
go to L 7 or whatever. So, I don't know what to say. I'm going
to say it first. I'm going to say it first. Okay, banned. Boom.
Done. Well, I mean Wow. Frogan got banned for way less. That's
on the hand just [__] I
Frogan didn't get banned for way less,
Frogan was just generally speaking Frogan was having like a normal
happy-go-lucky stream and then out of the blue where she's just
like, "YEAH, I DO HOPE I do hope all veterans get PTSD, okay?"
That was actually a way worse statement. Guys
Twitch made it to us. Uh they're strict and at Twitch got even
some some veteran asked the question and they said that they
would lock in on veteran related and he he just shut on them.
He he just What did he ask for? He asked for what reason? city
differ Be like, "Yeah, I went to Iraq. I went to Iraq and it's
actually Islam that's the biggest danger. You're the danger,
idiot. >> Check, if you're in the army and it's say you're
going to Iraq and you say no,
I'm staying home. Are you not like a deserter or something? Yeah,
you go to jail. Sure, if you're in the military, you're sure.
I don't understand it. Like Yes, I'm not going to rewrite history.
Okay, but when you're a soldier, when you're in the army, you're
in the army. Yeah, there are benefits of being in the army. Oh,
hold on. We we go to like later on. Yeah, we go but Hasan says
later on. Hasan has no problem with people No, no, no, they're
joining the military. Hasan doesn't have a people a problem with
people who deploy and go Oh, I really hated how Iraq went. He
literally said, like I actually think that if you came back and
you learned the lessons of Iraq, you thought it was really bad
and you had some consternation about sending people back in the
Middle East, then I have no problem with you. You're welcome
here. There's some There's some good things for like a school
and [__] like that being in the army. But sometimes
you get deployed and and whatever and I'm I'm
this is part of whatever. You can't just Oh, guys, I'm not
I'm not a right-wing guy. I'm not going. You want me to go to
Iraq? You want me to be deployed and do my job?
I'm not going to do that. Yeah, come on, bro. It's weird to paint
these guys as terrorists. So, that's random. It's so random.
It You're a danger to your family
and a danger to yourself, douchebag. I'm pretty sure that's what
Hasan means by terrorist in this case. It's like you're a bigger
terrorist than me because you are going to terrorize the people
around you being PTSD riddled. You're going to wake up in the
middle of the night and hit your wife. I think I think that's
what he's trying to cook with here, no? That's where That's what
it seems like to me. egg. Well, that's getting clipped. I don't
give a [__] dude. Shut the [__] up. If
you go to Iraq Rando, use a message as a starter or which
15 years out from Iraq, eat my balls.
Do you even have your balls remaining or did a [__]
IED explode them for you, dumbass? Shut the [__]
up. Talk Are you guys think terrorized in Okay, yeah, could go
either way. xQc L about
What the Who suggested Wait, ban whatever chat Okay, if you're
a mod, I know there aren't going to be any mods for xQc's chat
in here, but if you were a mod, hypothetically, ban whatever
chatter just suggested xQc attempt
What the [__] are you doing?
He's already got to read the tweet possibly in some of these
situations. You're going to make him read random chat messages?
That's [__] up. guy. I mean, I I don't give a [__]
Well, I mean, guys, this is not 1994,
okay? 66 month spin Wait, because somebody said something you
can say whatever you want to. But the guy could have said xQc
is not dumb? Yeah, but the brain process the the processing power
of his brain it takes to read and talk at the same time, he goes
back to the the he goes back to that, okay? It's rough. >> worst
thing in the in the world. I don't give a [__] If
you if you answer like this, you're wrong. You know Why would
you Why would you try to act like you're the master of the orchestrate
as a streamer and then lowers of the standards of random rage
baiters? Like why would you lower that and say Oh, oh.
Are we pretending Asmongold isn't the best rage baiter on the
Twitch platform?
That's literally how you build viewership. You just rage bait
over stuff. You just rage bait over stuff that's calculated.
Why are we pretending that's not a way to build your audience?
That's That's not something xQc does or anybody does. Well, this
guy said a bunch of Remember when xQc accused all of Kai Cenat's
friends of botting?
Remember? I remember. >> furs. Not mad. So, I'm going to
They were botting horribly and I'm going to say that They were
botting horribly.
Got him. It's almost like Kai Cenat's friends had like no moral
problem with just stealing. It's That's crazy, isn't it? I feel
like that's That's a crazy thing xQc said. All of the people
who are friends with Kai Cenat, they seem to just be like thieves
and thugs. Right, >> of xQc to say. Anybody? No, you're
a [__] idiot. Like who are you? No, you don't do
that. Yeah, it's both wrong, but in that case he's more wrong
because he should know better. We're an infinitely bigger terror
Go to Iraq and you learn that lesson, you realize that that was
wrong, you're welcome here. You come back from Iraq and you [__]
talk about how Woah, woah, woah. Iraq and you learn that lesson,
you realize that that was wrong, you're welcome here. You come
back from Iraq and you [__] That kind of just undoes
the whole thing of xQc saying this was about your like better
just being sent over, right? Hasan literally says the thing like
Oh, well, you learned that it would be fine. >> and talk
about how this was actually awesome and I [__] hate
Islam, then [__] you. You didn't learn anything.
You're goddamn cattle. You're sending other people like you to
be in I just love that Hasan has picked up cattle and started
using it, okay? And every time he uses it, every It's like the
perfect thing to call people because every single time Yo, Jibreel,
thank you for the five gifted. It's awesome that he uses it because
every single time
uses cattle, every single person who's like overly neurotic about
Hasan being an anti-Semite hears cattle. Every single time, okay?
Every single time they hear cattle and it like sends It sends
like a full body shock, okay? They get They get like actual mental
damage from Hasan saying cattle cuz they hear cattle and they're
like He's an anti-Semite!
He's an anti-Semite!
in a similar predic
Lightning bolts? Yeah. He's doing AoE shocks now. It's crazy.
>> yourself. Whatever I'll start livestreaming on YouTube
tomorrow. Suck my dick. Now, you're getting clipped.
Okay, well, I mean, [laughter] put it up, buddy. By who? The
people that have been literally begging for American sons and
daughters to go and die in Iran for the last 2 weeks?
Now, this is the part I wanted to watch for. I just hope that
xQc engages with the idea that this is Israel's war, that that
a whole bunch of like Asmongold have been arguing that it's like
actually no, it's in the American interest. Guys, they were going
to nuke They were going to nuke America in 2 weeks if we didn't
go. By people who keep going Yeah, based. No, we got to Kind
of getting sick of people leaning on cattle and to be honest.
Well, that's fair, okay? I have a lot of words for these same
concepts. So, I'll I'll switch it up. My vocabulary on dehumanizing
other people, Missy, is second to none, okay? You don't have
the spark, you're being filtered. You are cattle, you're an NPC,
you're a bot, you don't have a soul. There's no light behind
your eyes. I can say it in a million different ways. I can extol
how other people are not human by any measure in a million different
ways, okay? Yes, and I love to do it. >> more money to
Israel.
Those people
those people who were going to turn around and then now act as
though they give a [__]
about veterans
the same people like Asmongold who celebrated when that Navy
SEAL
uh with his Spiritually Israeli? What was the deeper Rama tweet
on this? I'm trying to think. The deeper Rama tweet was something.
It was like Oh, it was spiritually Israeli loses out to What
is it? There's a better term. It's zog something. Come on, I
can't think of it. I got to scroll. Give me a sec, I'm finding
it. Dude, this guy tweets a lot. Zogful. This is the one.
>> We don't say spiritually Israeli anymore, we say zogful,
okay? Zogful. It's good stuff. It's good stuff. with his uniform
had his [__] arm broken.
Really? That's what we're doing? If Twitch can apply this [__]
double standard when one veteran is getting their [__]
arm broken by an American congressperson for opposing America
waging Israel's wars, when Twitch doesn't [__] ban
Asmongold for laughing at that and saying Yeah, based and that
he deserved it, when Twitch literally doesn't say a single damn
thing >> Well, he's a jerk, I mean, I I saw the video,
I mean, they were trying to remove him from remove him from the
room. It's like he was saying everything. Stop talking. We're
going to break your arm. I mean, this is I mean, he's just rewriting
rewriting history. Like what? Think about that but then turns
around and tries to ban me for this [__] This platform,
I It's so [__] up that people will totally disconnect
from what that guy was protesting over. They won't talk about
it at all. They will just say, Well, actually he was disruptive
and so they wanted to remove him and because he wouldn't leave,
he got his arm broken. And they totally ignore the underlying
thing he was protesting.
Like I feel like
I don't It's so goofy to me, man. >> never [__]
come back here. Y'all are a bunch of dumb
who for being like Oh, you're going to get clipped. Yo, Weasley
little liar, thank you for the gifted sub. to RAF96.
Thank you. All right. dumb
doesn't even realize his own lived >> being smart ass.
I'm just saying you're not going to rewrite the the the the the
context because you want to. Like if I break into Congress and
I start saying, Yo, um I don't know. I don't know if I have the
correct take. I don't know if I have the correct take. I say
peace and love in the world, man. And then they remove him from
the room and I I I hold onto the door like a maniac and I I I
No, you're not going to stop him from talking. And then my arm
breaks, I'm not going to go Yo, guys. Yeah, I get Yo, look at
him breaking Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god.
I think the thing we're pointing out here, xQc, is that if you
were just saying peace and love, maybe they'd be a
>> I think that's the That's the feeling everybody has,
okay? Protesting Israel, arm broken.